but this is definitely gonna be a
different style vlog you're gonna see
some cheering you gonna see some maybe a
quiet moment or two
[Music]
in the hotel room in Indy here Bryant's
coming in with the biggest [ __ ] piece
of luggage I've ever seen nonetheless
big humongous day for Vayner supports
today blog even seeing some of the stuff
along the way today the DBS we have five
we have five corners in this draft they
all are gonna hit the combine right now
obviously the team is extremely excited
here with the agents Brian Tommy we're
here with we're here with the brains and
the power we're here with the looks in
general a very exciting day for all of
us here most of the teams been here in
Indy for several days I got in late last
night
headed to London excited for the sneaker
drop South by Southwest this weekend but
this is definitely gonna be a different
style blog you're gonna see some
cheering you can see some maybe a quiet
moment or two will edit very carefully
but nonetheless very excited for our
guys overall you know just very proud of
of the whole crew and how hard they've
worked over the last eight to 12 weeks
and then on a separate note the
marketing front has been extremely
excited and a lot of you guys have been
interacting and so we'll see what
happens
big big big day for the firm
I like how I live I finished my tweet do
for these kids what agents should be
doing I'm just [ __ ] I'm getting very
hammy there he is
oh yeah there he is
however he asked me last night if I was
nervous I said no just CB Jews just
maybe it's like a house or they are like
today I got lucky I got a huge call with
ten o'clock so I feel like I'm gonna
miss them letting a bunch of guys in the
same man I'm really nervous about Josh's
run I just want it over with let's go
Josh let's go Josh let's go baby orange
sneakers let's [ __ ] go let's go Josh
and who this situation that start but a
reasonably here there and they want a
job so I just like these kids excursion
start come on Josh yeah yeah Josh let's
go Josh yeah Josh let's go baby first
our ventless [ __ ]
[Music]
this is classic human he's a loser
I'll give you the best definition
excuses if you have excuses you're a
[ __ ] loser
[Music]
this way you can have a conversation
with doesn't get build that rapport let
me know okay okay okay okay all right
that's why I said actually no bestie
it's like AJ what would you run like a
five six okay
hi great now we're all good business
he's been trying to broke the 3d am i
man I read a 5-2 at age twenty years I'm
like that so five six
who's faster me or you you I'm saluting
it's like a grip is the reverse of every
conversation we've ever had
[Laughter]
yeah I'm much quicker than I am
what's what's the crafty drill that
shows your craftiness cuz I would crush
that
[Music]
[Music]
so we haven't shown a whole lot today
but we've met up with a bunch of the
guys we're in an area where we couldn't
film now we rush to the airport because
our flight got delayed by three hours
and trying to get on it
good day on all got a little piece of
the combine hey JD did his thing a lot
of stuff guys
none of them have it's like you're
supposed to see together these night
sinners so changes in the earlier one
but you have to pay for it
yes that's my mother
[Music]
the updated map it's not fancy so she
was an economy in that first class they
would let him switch some going on the
earlier flight see about it see it by
Gary Tom the bunch of trash broke I'm
making all this flight
[Music]